I mean it's really stunning at what's
happened the the attack that the
outright coup d'etat I guess democracy
and against constitutional governance
that's happened in the past 20 months
because we've seen you know James
Madison but um
at that Jefferson and and Adams and the
other framers put the first amendment in
the put freedom of speech and expression
into the First Amendment because all of
the other amendments depend on it
and we saw them immediately go after the
first amendment in fact
in October of 2019
when the virus was already almost
certainly circulating in Wuhan
um they had this you know this pandemic
um
uh a tabletop simulation in New York
called uh called event 201
and were they
were they they did a you know they did a
simulation of a coronavirus a global
coronavirus at a time when it was Bill
Gates it was April Haynes the former
deputy director of the CIA
uh pharmaceutical people John Johnson
and Johnson people from the
the uh from the uh social media and from
the mainstream media and they're all
sitting around a table
simulating what's going to happen if a
coronavirus pandemic hits is quite
extraordinary but the response
that they're talking about has nothing
to do with a Medical Response
it's all about using the pandemic
of airing militarized response and a
monetized response they use the pandemic
as an excuse to clamp down totalitarian
controls and they spend the entire force
that anybody can go and look at this you
know it's still on YouTube
and it's and you know a two-hour
discussion talking about how to solve
how to censor
social media when people start saying
that the coronavirus was laboratory
generated and you have
the head of Chinese CDC George gay oh
there you have the see I had the person
who is now Obama's highest ahead of the
National Security Agency and that's what
they're all talking about
oh and as soon as the pandemic came
that's the first thing they did is they
started censoring everybody well once
they did that and what Madison said
is the reason they put it in the first
amendment is because once you give
license to a government
this island speech the government has a
license to commit any atrocity including
abolishing all the other amendments so
then they got rid of they you know the
other part of the first amendment is
religion
they shut down the churches for a year
without due process without any science
being shown without any public hearings
no notice and comment rulemaking
and they kept the liquor stores open as
essential businesses
oh you know which I don't have an
objection a lot of people liquor stores
are essential but
liquor stores are not in the
Constitution and churches are so there
should have been some
public National discussion of that
and some science demonstrating that this
was something that was going to work and
they shut down jury trials
is that the sixth amendment Seventh
Amendment says
no American shall be denied the right of
a trial
before his peers in case their
controversies exceeding 25 in value
will they passed the prep Act and the
cares act I said if a vaccine company or
any other corporation that says it's
involved in counter measures
injuries or kills you no matter how
negligent they are no matter how
Reckless
no matter how Grievous your injury you
cannot sue them
a property rights they close a million
businesses with no due process no just
compensation they got rid of all of the
prohibitions against
or in the searches and seizures you know
with all this track and tracing
surveillance that they Implement and
and they got Rift due process of law
government is no longer by public
hearing and you know notice and comment
rule making and you show me the science
and all cross-examine you and you
cross-examine me
it's just one doctor
who's saying put on masks
uh you know lockdown without any
scientific justification no argument and
that is so frightening and so
disconcerting to I think anybody who
understands how democracy it got rid of
every Amendment except the Second
Amendment which is the guns the rest of
them are all gone right
um so all right so they got rid of it
all
one doctor
what are the chances that that doctor
would also be one of two people who
appears potentially to have been
responsible for the pandemic in the
first place yeah I mean that's the big
question
[Music]
foreign